hello everybody my name is Brian and I
allowance and we are both from developer
relations on the Google cloud platform
and we're going to try to experiment
today so tell us more about yeah we'd
like to start just really having a good
open conversation with you developers
talk with you about Google cloud
platform and about cloud as a whole
obviously it's a little too late for
this video to answer any of your
questions but for future videos if
you've any questions just put them in
the comments section down here and like
under this video window I think the
floor of the studio yeah and you know we
would love to answer them and if we
can't answer them and I mean between
Brian and I we should be able to answer
most of them mostly brian hansen about
me and it's a given we won't know all
the answers but yeah if we don't we know
the people that do exactly love to bring
it out there and answer them for you
fantastic so yeah so questions
conversation topics like things you
would like to hear about cloud platform
or anything goes give us shots I king of
go go anything goes so for today I think
we'll try a little a few questions here
between us to get things going totally
unrehearsed completely on her so you
will see flubs here and there things
we've seen a few array so as so Lawrence
so like what is cloud to you like so
like in previous six how would like your
previous experiences developing software
and designing software have changed if
you had cloud so I guess I'm quite
experienced in like designing software
and developing a little bit and
experience probably to the length of it
made me a little cynical so forgive me
if you comes across as that but I think
cloud for me is like it's one of those
terms that we as an industry and I don't
mean any particular company but just we
as an industry haven't done a great job
in the past of really articulating what
it is and what it means and I guess I
could give one example that it's a funny
little story if you feel then don't go
so I used to be an architect on
like a financial services platform and
we build products for Wall Street and we
build products for financial analysts on
Wall Street and generally the way that
you build a product is that like an
architect will command architect talks
to the business people gathers the
business requirements takes a look at
the infrastructure that we have in place
and you know joins the dots so for
example it might be would build a
product that is like providing some
financial analytics and so you know we
have a feed of fundamentals and we have
a feed of like data and we have a feed
of his this point it at all lines and
boxes it's all lines and boxes exactly
software yet not software yeah its lines
and boxes and Visio diagrams and yeah
you know and cylinders don't forget the
cylinder it's hunters databases are
cylinders then up boxes and you know so
we draw all these things up and you know
before we get developers involved you
know would draw this up and then we
generally have like a big fluffy cloud
right so we have all our lines and boxes
of our feeds and our databases and a big
fluffy cloud and then like you know a PC
connected to it a mobile device
connecting to it like a terminal
connecting so that's like the internet
and everything that was like everything
hidden behind it and I'm sure if you
like open Vizio or other like there's
always drafting tools today there's
always an icon for a big fluffy cloud
okay and that that was the cloud and I
can remember like you know for me the
next step is once I've designed this and
I figured out all these feeds and where
I'm getting all this data like I would
bring the ops people in and I remember
specifically the best ops guy I've ever
worked with Mike I remember his name I
remember it will Scott something is not
scott guthrie I remember Scott something
and I remember having this conversation
with him and presenting the thing to him
and he looked through and I thought I'd
done a fabulous job of pitching my
architecture to him and his job would be
then to think about how many servers do
we have running this how do we secure
that how do we make sure the servers are
patched managed power yadda yadda yadda
all this kind of stuff I remember like
doing this fabulous presentation that I
prepared like four weeks and giving it
to this guy to get him on board and he
said four words to me
and these are words that I can share on
video don't worry sir so what do you
think the four words were um I love it
he's it forwards where there is no cloud
wait okay okay listen this is ten years
ago yeah bat ok about that so where is
he coming from with that so where he was
coming from when he was exactly right
was because if you think about the
complexity of running an application
like this ok security and manageability
like I same virus scanning even like the
number of servers that you need to run
this thing we had actually do a
calculation that would look at our
traffic and then would say this was
going to be a java application running
on a weblogic app server i would say ok
we looked at our the traffic that would
have and looked at the number of users
would figure out how many you know like
based on the cpu based on the networking
activity so he's thinking just like
straight logistics like how do you get
the hardware you need to do that like
what networking infrastructure do you
need like out of the switches workload
balancing how much storage do we need
yeah you can't just hand wave that away
and like I draw I did behind a fluffy
cloud gosh ok well how does that change
now like listen so that's not really
what we think of as cloud now but it
kind of is what and I think that's the
main thing and that's like the magic
that the perceived magic that I is an
architect would do is like draw a fluffy
cloud and hide away all and then likes
it all just works yeah and it all just
works like that is a reality now it's no
longer a perceived magic right because I
mean we work with the Google cloud
platform and I'm gonna go do my superman
thing go you know we work with the
Google cloud platform now and so the
nice thing about that is if we build
applications that run for example on App
Engine yep and it was funny that was
talking about was javon weblogic and
brave engine supports Java which makes
me very happy and you know then all of
those complexities of scaling up and
when you need it and scaling down when
you don't need it god you're only paying
for what you use so now that's all real
that's all real you know because in his
to go back to my friend who said there
is no cloud you know he would look at
the amount of traffic that we need will
calculate the number of servers that we
need for that and then we had like an
algorithm based on like a
tub curve type thing and what you call
that a binary curve to say him and I
think we calculated the average number
of servers and we multiplied that by 2
root 2 and that would give us like the
ninety-five percent estimate for you
know for traffic and so like we might
need 10 servers for traffic but would
end up with 28 servers and for the times
like from outside of nine to five you
know that goes 28 notes till sitting
there not being years average times
we're using 10 and 18 of them were
unused and for the sake of like peak
time we might use 23 24 25 of them but
like now it cloud like now we can talk
about that kind of fluffy thing and all
of that magic is going on for it really
exists and it really really exists so
I'd love to have I'd love to have Scott
on a future show and I asked him is
there a cloud now like my job okay so I
had kind of a related experience you
know like so I spent many years working
on a system for distributing files
around many locations so that they were
always available from all of these sites
that the organization worked at and you
know we were trying to create the
illusion that all of these files were
available everywhere and realistically
you know you would keep a hot set of
files or recent things or some subset of
what you could actually afford to keep
their at some sites and maybe other
sites would have everything and you have
like too many copies of everything
really because you don't need the ball
Asset Management's a difficult problem
exactly and and you know you look at at
things like Google Cloud storage which
is you know blob storage service in the
cloud and it essentially is that entire
system that we built like just ravey you
as a service as a service right so so if
I was in that yeah i think the entire
product doesn't even need to be built
like in that way so i would save a huge
amount of time so you could have really
focused on building out the user
experience exactly instead of the
plumbing in the infrastructure yep and
you know what we wanted to build on top
of that good it was all just necessary
foundation to get to what we were trying
to do you
and so with ya there are only so many
hours in the day and so if you're
spending all that time and all those
cycles building that plumbing it's like
think about the things that you're now
building exactly and particularly
nowadays I feel folks have much more of
a demand for a rich user experience than
they used to have you know things that
are where acceptable 10 years ago
completely unacceptable today and
because now you have the luxury of being
able to hide behind that big fluffy
cloud you know with the cloud storage
then now you can focus on building a
better user experience and such a thing
like that totally so it do you have a
feature of cloud that kind of gets you
excited yeah so like there's there's a
bunch of things like so many things
about cloud that gets me really excited
i mean like big picture like the whole
cloud space is super exciting right now
i think we've gotten to the point where
you can create a a model of the hardware
we used to have to run all these things
so you've got your servers and you got
your networks and switches and and
everything that used to have to go to a
data center in do by hand there's an API
for and that is super useful incredibly
exciting and and allows a layer a level
of automation that just wasn't possible
before and you know speaks is like but I
don't think we're done there right like
this is the this is the next step of
figuring out okay now that these are
these things that used to be physical or
abstract concepts yeah are they the
right abstractions we want for billing
software in the future mmm and I think
you know I think we can do better right
oh absolutely and you know so there's
things that are really exciting right
now you know so App Engine is really
interesting in that space I think docker
is super exciting as a bunch of stuff
going on there so cloud is a whole super
exciting I think in the in compute
engine terms like we've got a load
balancer that's basically Google's
datacenter level load balancing
available as a feature you know for you
to use we've got block storage where
it's super consistent and that's like
its primary design goal is consistency
great for running databases on and
things like that but i think if i want
to just like i like something pick one
pick one i'm actually going to put a
gopher to your head and it's good to
pick one only one okay i think i would
have to pick
notifications in cloud storage so so
cloud storage is this blob store in the
sky you can you can push files to it and
you can get them back from anywhere in
the world and it has essentially
subscription notification so you can say
at this HTTP endpoint that's my
application I want you to send the
metadata for every single change that
happens in this bucket nice so you can
build workflow and you can build deep
integration between cloud storage and
any application whether that's running
on google cloud or not nice so so like
it go back to your video scenario so if
you're building a video app and you've
got people all over the world shooting
footage for a movie or something like
that and then somebody put some new
footage everybody's going to be notified
so you can get like notifications to
tell people about it you could kick off
a transcoding process you can just
deeply integrate it within your whole
out cool cool anything you need to do
and there's an API for that there's an
API for that there's an API for
everything they used to say there's an
app for that now always say there's an
API for there's an API for that so if
you had to pick one what's your if i put
the gopher to my head yep um oh there's
so many i think one for me that actually
the very first thing you know what they
say about first love is the one that you
remember so the first love for me with a
Google Cloud was actually Java ok and I
know it's a surprise I'm from Python
backing from Python bankrupt yeah I've
got some great stuff to say about Python
but maybe for a future video but i think
it's like you know cuz i work came from
a java background and then i work from
microsoft for many years and move more
into the asp.net background but I really
one of the things that disappointed me
about Java years ago was how hard it was
and how expensive it was for you to put
java stuff publicly oh right right like
if you had an app server like for j2ee
thing like those things cost in the tens
of thousands of dollars okay so compared
to your like PHP a poor way my file a
nap or you know where you two bucks a
month or even over server or that kind
of and it was like I really like to be
able to showcase some Java work but I
couldn't ok I was short of like putting
an app server like a tom cat or
something like that on a machine under
my desk and opening port 80 on my lyrica
java programmer and you've made some
awesome thing a job and you want to show
it off yeah what do you do I'm applying
for job it's a Java job and I want to
show some java stuff ok can't do it
then what comes along but App Engine and
i know i'm holding the girlfriend now so
he probably feel a bit disappointed him
but he's been different language and
it's unlike App Engine and now i can use
eclipse and i can put a simple plug-in
into eclipse and i can start writing
code in Java and I can deploy it to App
Engine and I'm not even paying a monthly
fee I'm paying based on usage okay so
like this is the case where it's scales
were down really well in addition to
setting up yeah and actually I haven't
been working at Google that long and as
part of my interview process i've had
this algorithm that i've been working on
for years where it's like i do
predictive analysis of the stock market
okay so take a look at like the history
of a stock price and then take a guess
from there what it's going to be at and
I thought okay here's a great example
for me too and I had originally written
this in Java and I moved it to c sharp
and I dusted off my old Java and put it
in a nap spot and I'm spot is where you
host App Engine apps right and so from
my actual interview my first interview
here at Google I showed this and I was
on that particular day it was really
interesting because it was predicting
that Google would spike and it will go
up and I told my interviewers because
you're talking to me how'd it turn out
did it they hired me good to go well we
saw that we went over a thousand dollars
soon afterwards rights yeah okay so
fantastic thank you very much for this
time together and thank you viewers yeah
thanks for watching all the way to the
end so are you interested in seeing more
stuff like this yes or no like other
topics you would like to hear hit up the
comments and we'll be in touch and do
more talk to you soon thank you bye
alrighty ok so we're recording now we
are absolutely recording now cool
outtakes have begun yes they have we
haven't even begun that intake today
respect to go for no respect to go for
that's true I was crying over maybe we
can even defer to him for some questions
if I get stuck you know good talk to